hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades before we crack on with this
one I wanted to thank those who have
chosen to support me in the support a
creator event it's massively appreciated
and helps me make more fortnight content
like this one you guys you're awesome so
we've had season six with us for a while
now and now that everything has started
to settle down a little it's possible to
find those underappreciated landing
spots which will net you legendary loot
and in most cases a rift nearby to get
you anywhere you want to be so here are
six perfect landing spots for easy wins
and more importantly places to drop
where you can choose your engagement
throughout the entire duration of the
game as usual I've saved my favorite for
last
although number one on the list is a
beauty - season six brought as a castle
I was hoping for expresses so along I
was certain this place would be heavy
with action from every single drop but
after the first week I never saw another
player drop here again it sounds strange
I know but this place became a ghost
town the only time I saw action here was
when the bus was directly overhead so
why is it so special
well let me break it down firstly it's a
high starting point meaning you can pop
your chute lower to the ground and land
earlier no need to wait seemingly ages
to get your boots on the ground on the
negative side there's only seven chests
up in here so this is not worth dropping
out as a squad but in solos it's got
potential the castle offers great sight
lines to junk Junction and haunted hills
allowing you to peek at your enemies who
are also after a slow start and due to
the high ground advantage they don't
stand a chance
alternatively if the circle is favorable
you could drop down and take those 11
chests in haunted hills or another 12 at
Junction but without a doubt the
greatest thing about this landing spot
are those rips nearby you can follow the
circle slowly if that's your bug and
third party any players scrapping be
warned though you'll not
get much action dropping at the castle
it even allowed me to complete a battle
past challenge with only 18 people left
that's how relaxing a drop this one is
of course you'll still need some skill
to beat the players in the final circle
I'll just bait the try hard ones into a
trap and dance and if you super lucky
the last player will turn and run in
fear choice the little things that make
this a good landing spot especially
those rifts it turns an average location
into a beast of a starting spot my
favorite place to go from the castle
rift is actually the next place on the
list let's drop at the motel if the
leaks are right this place won't be here
forever so love it while you can
the motel is such a small location that
if the bus path is far enough away it
will go unnoticed with seven chests to
locate the motel is pretty good also
I've noticed a scar here regularly
around one in every six games during my
test yeah you know why this is a great
landing spot those lovely rigs there's
only 12 on the map during season 6 so I
like to use them for mobility and I
think that you should consider it too
the trees around the motel will be
useful formats but it's the quarry
shaped like an umbrella which once again
doesn't get any attention these days
farm the stone to your heart's content
and there's even two marketing chests
for good measure
[Music]
going back to the motel on drifting away
is the ideal method to progress in the
mid-game if for some reason there are no
rifts here just go south over to the der
Berger they'll be something there
instead
here's another loop run you could
consider depending on the angle of the
bus it's the weakest on the list but it
does include the fabled rift spawn
nearby the truckstop situated below
retail row and just next to the track
our ultimate aim here is to collect the
four chests and take stock of our
surroundings just north are those riffs
from here you'll be able to decide the
best course of action or a rotation as
those pros college retail or the track
the track can be hugely profitable with
ten possible chests bonds and
above-average random loot drops I would
have suggested landing here straight
away but it's difficult to know if there
will be any one landing here with you
just before making this video I tried
one last time to land there and there
was 10 people so for that reason I use
the truck stop to get kitted up and then
make a choice from there there's a room
nearby too but I'm not sure if they're
going to stay for the whole season so
let's not include that just now this
spot is different from the rest and it's
more tactical it isn't about staying
unharmed until the final fight but if
you do want to stay up to calm way walk
Southwest to brutal bridge another spot
from season 5s video Oh segue speaking
of last season
[Music]
back in season five we showed you el
pueblo el público the community went on
to call this place west world I don't
mind what you call it as long as it's
not Wicky Wicky wild with your world
wiki wild wild west this is still a
beast of a drop but just like last time
we spoke about this you will not go here
alone so be ready for a battle with a
teen loot chests this will have you
ultra prepared for the sweaty
confrontation in the last circle last
season there was rifts galore to escape
West world but they're not here this
season but don't you dare worry if you
know about the secret rift it's still
here - down in the bottom right hand
corner of the map follow the waterfall
but carefully I said carefully make your
way down and you'll see a rift or two I
used to jump straight into them but on
more than one occasion I went straight
through the damn thing what do you mean
I didn't miss it
are you talking about can we move on
before anyone realizes that I'm the
worst player in the lobby the quick
mention - 3 reactive landing spots that
you should consider ever heard of the
story of the three little pigs while
their houses are here in fort 19 season
6 half of lazy links to the right of
Paradise Palms
and under greasy Grove all made up of
different materials these don't
constitute great landing spots within
themselves but I wanted to make you
aware as they are completely ignored so
if you've been to the toilet and you get
back late use one of these it's pretty
safe location all three of them each can
hold up to three chests there's no
grifts nearby resources aren't too
cracking it's basically a safety net to
stop you becoming cannon fodder the best
way to use these is actually mid to late
game depending on the circle I'm pretty
certain loot improves as the game goes
on so by that I mean if there's 20
people left I'm pretty sure that the
chests give you better loot but of
course I can't prove that it's just a
theory at the moment do me a favor and
let me know if you find better worse or
the exact same loot in the late game she
is darling
[Music]
and finally the greatest landing spot in
season six it's a beast wailing woods
and the new cabins and bunkers nearby it
really comes down to that rift hidden
away under the old maze which is now a
shady secret government facility this
rift is here 100% of the time you are
guaranteed to get away but it's all the
other things that make this the greatest
landing spot in season six there's six
chests to grab in and around the bunker
which you can loot without fear of being
shot in the back the acoustics down low
will allow you to hear any rushes
setting up traps wherever you jump down
is a great idea because people is dumb
inside the bunker is enough metal to
start your own foundry and outside you
can't see the wood for the trees in a
matter of minutes you'll be loaded with
mats and just up to the west are columns
of stone if you want that too depending
on the circle it's possible to go to
another spot we highlighted last season
the good old architects house and that
double chests spawn at the ice cream
truck north of that potentially even
more rifts to wailing woods is so damn
good should you arrive late and miss
your chance to get the bunker there are
cabins nearby with loot in the basement
so even a bad landing here should result
in good loot and resources I'd also like
to say that the three chests that can
spawn by the room spot are also ideal
but I don't know what the house from up
is going to do soon so I'll keep that
theory for another day
in fact I'll probably come back once all
the rooms have been activated because
the map will likely change for Halloween
[Music]
so what do you think any of these spots
you like any of these spots I've
completely ruined and now you hate me
let me know if you found any great areas
to drop and also if you've seen any
Easter eggs in season six please give me
a shout right did you know that everyone
stops watching my videos at seven
minutes so if you are still hearing this
you're a freaking legend thanks for
sticking around and now I'm going to
shamelessly plug my support to create a
link my gamertag is Adam arrow if you
ever think you'll be spending VBox
consider adding my name before you do if
everyone does it it will net me a few
dollars and will help me keep creating
content on YouTube you can do this in
save the world or in battle royale
please use this function regardless if
you help me or not choose someone
smaller youtubers and twitch streamers
in particular they need your support to
survive against the ninjas of the world
right I'll shut up thanks for staying
till the end I'll see you next time you
are wiki Wow a Wicky wild wild west Jim
West desperado Rough Rider
no you don't want neither none of this
six warning why do I know the lyrics to
Wicky Wicky wild life